ich habe nachgezählt nur noch 20 mal
türchen aufmachen emotionen rauslassen
schon ist heiligabend bei der damen und
herren endlich all die wilden verwandten
sehen die wir monatelang nicht treffen
sollten wie schön
ja und sie in der heiligen nacht wurde
uns eine dritte welle geboren
am mittwoch haben merkel und die
länderchefs den teil shutdown
bis zum 10 januar verlängert quasi als
ihre letzte amtshandlung vor den ferien
was die nächsten wochen sagt uns keiner
was wir machen sollen keine paare kinder
wie mutti ist ja nicht aus der welt
wir haben einfach nur gesagt wir stehen
jederzeit zur verfügung wenn irgend
etwas ist was wo man sagt die hütte
brennt sage ich meine es ist notwendig
dann sind wir jederzeit bereit uns
wieder zu treffen echt dazu werden ihr
bereit
man könnte fast meinen dass wir heuer
beruf advent advent die hütte brennt
hoffentlich entpuppt sich die lockerung
über die festtage nicht doch als großer
fehler
zehn personen aus beliebig vielen
haushalten dafür haben wir uns gerade
sogar die baby ja kritisiert die belgier
um himmels willen von wegen die ganze
welt beneidet uns um unser pandemie
management bleibt das prinzip hoffnung
wir müssen hoffen dass die menschen
vernünftig sind laut deutschlandtrend
wollen 45 prozent der deutschen an
weihnachten ihre kontakte stark oder
sehr stark einschränken 51 prozent
wollen sich dagegen an den feiertagen
wenig oder überhaupt nicht beschränken
51 prozent sagen dass darauf das virus
so party ja dass wir uns küssen gewissen
liebt feste es liebt feste und es freut
sich garantiert tierisch weil hier in
deutschland jedes bundesland weiter
gnadenlos sein ding durchzieht natürlich
so was gelernt berlin locker über
weihnachten weniger öffnet dafür aber
die hotels in sachsen darf man auch ins
hotel aber da will keiner hin baden
württemberg scherze wester komplett aus
und so weiter und so weiter
eigentlich wissen alle dass die ganze
lockerung quatsch ist aber wir ziehen
das jetzt eisern durch aus prinzip
für die gute stimmung und wegen
folgender gewagte these ich glaube das
ist doch in den familien so ist
das waren sich ja deswegen weihnachten
tritt weil man auch eng sympathien
füreinander hat weil man eben gerne
zusammen ist nein
familien die sich mögen was nimmt in der
laube frage warum machen wir stumpf
weiter mit dem teilstaat trotz 400 bis
500 toten jeden tag möglicherweise wäre
ein richtiger lockdown schon im oktober
doch die bessere lösung gewesen
aber statt endlich über neue strategien
zu reden streitet man in berlin lieber
über geld wer soll das alles bezahlen
wir haben jetzt diese schulden gemacht
und die schulden werden nach aufgenommen
aber es geht natürlich nicht endlos ist
ja klar dass wir das nicht bis ultimo
fortführen können die bei super politik
muss jetzt endgültig vorbei sagt damit
diese schuldenmacherei auch ein ende
findet wer soll das am ende zurückzahlen
tja da fragen sie mich was hui ist das
spannend zahlen die länder mehr oder
doch der bund so völlig egal
das geld ist weg das ist nämlich das
geniale unsere corona strategie ist
tierisch teuer und drückt die
infektionszahlen kaum jetzt die gute
nachricht armin laschet verspricht schon
für januar zitat kluge konzepte und
langfristige perspektiven heißt also
übersetzt die konzepte bis jetzt
warendorf und kurzfristig super
krisenkommunikation ein echtes
armutszeugnis
warum haben wir im gegensatz zu
nachbarländern den echten lockdown
vermieden weil bei uns immer noch das
primat des konsums gilt natürlich im
kern geht es immer zuerst um die
wirtschaft selbst wenn schulen bei uns
offen bleiben machen wir das nicht für
die kinder
unsere kinder müssen betreut werden denn
wenn wir den den wirtschaftlichen lockt
dann auch verhindern wollen es ist ja
der zusammenhang schule und kita hatte
den ziel und zweck auch um die
wirtschaft am laufen zu lassen
ach so ja wäre es da nicht konsequenter
die kinder gleich in die fabrik zu
schicken
konsum geht vor infektionszahlen peter
altmaier hat es in der bild wenigstens
ganz offen ausgesprochen
ich zitiere einkaufen ist eine
patriotische aufgabe steht der stolz mit
seinem fahrrad ohne stützräder sicher es
hilft dem gebeutelten einzelhandel schon
leider braucht man zum shoppen aber
dieses na wie heißt das noch geld
richtig geld wovon manche deutsche am
ende des corona jahres jetzt nicht mehr
ganz so viel haben trotzdem shoppen ist
staatsbürger pflicht
in der dunkelsten stunde des
einzelhandels kommt es auf jeden
einzelnen an
auch auf dich auf mich habe ich doch
gesagt alle deutschen dem konsum fähigen
alter erhalten jetzt von peter altmaier
ihren einberufungsbescheid eben warst du
noch ein kind jetzt siehst du für
deutschland an die shop in front
wahrscheinlich sehen sie dich nie wieder
wenn du stellst dich dem albtraum einer
deutschen fußgängerzone in der
vorweihnachtszeit steht einen mann bei
pinkey bei deichmann bei nanu nana und
sogar in der geruch solle einer frag
nicht was dein land dir kaufen kann kauf
für dein land
das ist der spirit award insel
fußgängerzone wo sich jetzt wieder
schlangen bilden wegen der neuen
abstandsregel für größere geschäfte nur
noch ein kunde pro 20 quadratmeter die
folge man steht draußen wieder an und
fängt sich mit glück stadt gerona mal
wieder sonne oldschool standard
erkältung betrifft läden über 800
quadratmeter inklusive gefahren an die
ich noch gar nicht gedacht hatte stellen
sie sich einen großen super rat mit mit
1000 quadratmeter verkaufsfläche vor wo
sich die kunden dann verirren werden sie
haben ja wahnsinnig viel platz da um
sich herum das ist völlig und
sachgerecht schatz sagt dem suchtrupp
ich bin irgendwo zwischen herbst nun
hören aber ich weiß nicht wie lange
meine vorräte noch reichen sehr
realistisches problem
und wer bitte denkt an die armen
supermarktmitarbeiter kunden die da
draußen im eisregen warten mussten sind
wahrscheinlich noch mieser gelaunt als
sonst wir schauen mal live zu valerie
niehaus sie arbeitet als kassiererin bei
einem discounter dem wir nicht nennen
wollen nur so viel der name ist das
gegenteil von brutto frau nie aus wie
war denn ihr 2020 einfach nur schön ich
weiß das klingt verrückt am ende von so
einem jahr aber wir kassiererinnen haben
so viel zuspruch gekriegt also jetzt wo
wir als systemrelevant sind nicht da ist
der kontakt zum kunden noch mal
intensiver geworden entschuldigen sie an
ihre maske vergessen glücklich du
[ __ ]
man kann so viel zurück ja glaube ich
aber ich meine eigentlich ist es kann
mit zuspruch alleine nicht getan
im frühjahr als wir uns durch die große
klopapier krise geholfen haben da ist es
doch wirklich von überall irre was die
leisten so viele warme worte
wer in diesen tagen an einer
supermarktkasse sitzt oder regale
gefüllt der macht einen der schwersten
jobs die es zur zeit gibt danke dass sie
da sind für ihre mitbürger und
buchstäblich den laden am laufen halten
sind denn so wunderbar einer inneren
laden arbeiten verstehen sie das an bord
spielen von der kanzlerin ja ein
wortspiel das hat sie ganz gut
hingesetzt jetzt ist aber der bruttolohn
bei vollzeitbeschäftigten in ihrer
branche im vergleich zum letzten jahr
sogar gesunken konnte man gerade lesen
das ist ja jetzt kein corona bonus in
dem sinne einer moment es gab ja boni
nur halt meistens in form von
rabattgutscheinen für den eigenen laden
also bei netto zum beispiel 200 euro
einkaufs rabatt gut dafür muss ich beim
netto für 1000 euro einkaufen aber egal
oder rewe und penny
da kriegen die mitarbeiter reise
gutscheine nur gültig beim
reiseunternehmen von rewe und penny aber
es ist doch trotzdem die schöne geste
jeder verreist gerne reise gutscheine
medizinisch ist das denn man kann doch
gerade nirgendwo hin reisen kann ihm
später außerdem es geht auch nicht immer
nur um geld herreweghe das ist möglich
sie abschließend um etwas bitten
in diesen zeiten schenken sie dem
verkäufer der verkäuferin im supermarkt
in der trikot in der drogerie vielleicht
einfach mein lächeln mehr kann eine
frauen ist im leben ist ein lächeln von
jetzt sparen ja allein die kaufland lidl
gruppe macht in diesem jahr
schätzungsweise zwölf prozent mehr
umsatz das wären etwa 140 milliarden da
muss noch mehr drin sein als ein lächeln
ein paar gutscheine
das kommt bestimmt noch und kaum habe
ich gesagt bringt mit der filialleiter
meinen dezember bonus danke wer noch
nicht nötig gewesen
beim bonus sind 50 treueherzen
fußball bildchen moment mal fünf mal
jogi löw nach dem ja nur bilder von dem
versager jetzt reicht's nähe ich bin
raus ich kündige das verstehe ich
valerie niehaus
ja und dann gab es diese woche noch die
entscheidende schlacht im krieg zwischen
bayern und österreich im grunde ein
sie hat söder versus kurz der junge
sieht wollte seinen pisten auch für
deutsche urlauber offenhalten gegen die
ausdrückliche weisung aus münchen hat
dann aber doch klein beigegeben weil er
ja auch noch klein ist nur die schweiz
lässt uns noch ein für schiefern heißt
für die meisten fällt der skiurlaub wohl
aus dietmar wischmeyer ist alles andere
als enttäuscht
wischmeyer sachbuch der bekloppten und
bescheuerten nach karneval und
kreuzfahrt rottet bewohner nun also
dankenswerterweise die dritte plage aus
den bekloppten skiurlaub während
karneval in hässlicher umgebung
stattfindet und die kreuzfahrer in
schwimmenden knästen vor sich hin faulen
ist der ski urlaub wirklich ein totaler
krieg gegen den alpenraum wieso heißt
das überhaupt wintersport dafür steigen
tagestouristen früh um 2 in köln oder
nürnberg mit ihrem sex spielzeug in
einen bus um nachmittags im schnee die
evolution hinter sich zu lassen dafür
extra in die alpen die evolution kann
man auch besiegen wenn man zu hause auf
allen vieren durch die bude schleicht
und die ziege booms billiger und besser
für die umwelt er wegen der party und
einfach nur spaß haben und gute laune
sind es auch gar nicht jeder bei warum
die notfallambulanzen mit noch mehr
frisch gebrochenen herzen verstopfen
es reicht auch sich im alten ballermann
abzufüllen bis der auswurf nach jagatee
schmeckt doch wehe dem der sich traut
das menschenrecht des mitteleuropäers
auf zweimal ski urlaub pro jahr
anzutasten
allein hamburg ein bundesland mit extra
skiferien schickt in jedem winter
300.000 bürger auf die piste und wer zu
hause bleibt versteht in den februar
ferien im regen
in den alpen wird eine fläche größer als
der bodensee mit schneekanonen ballert
das verbraucht pro jahr drei mal so viel
wasser wie die stadt münchen
was für eine bekloppte welt zur rettung
des klimas sollten wir uns alle mit dem
scheiß fahrrad bei wind und wetter in
der autofreien stadt die kröten
abfrieren aber mit dem hubschrauber auf
die letzten unberührten gipfel zum heli
ski das ist okay oder wie muss es das
geben
ja das muss es geben definitiv weil
insoweit ist ja unsere welt braucht dass
die luft da oben ist halt doch sehr dünn
was aber wird aus den abgenudelten
gipfeln wenn da kein schnee mehr fällt
wie wäre es mit daunen mountainbiking da
kann man sich auch die geräten brechen
genauso viele murmeltiere überfahren und
die gerölllawine fegt den schluchten sie
ist ihrer letzten tour orte weg und
küsste andererseits hallo leute ich
bin's der heute-show hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal der stelle
[Musik]